hello there reject nation I'm Greg
outlet I'm Joan Humphrey
we're gonna watch nish Kumar thank you
for electing Trump Conan on TBS
this is from a 24:29 teen it's a top
reward video requests basically whatever
video you requested this reports here we
you must put up on YouTube and hopes it
doesn't get blocked worldwide this is
from Jay n Valente let's watch some
stand-up comedy consecrated Church I
mean on Friday and Saturday this music
and comedy and on Sunday it's a church
and it turns out I love performing in
churches which makes sense on a
structural level because ultimately a
church is a building that's designed for
people to speak it and for other people
to listen to and appreciate that speech
so the sight lines are incredible the
acoustics are phenomenal
I think it's nice occasionally for
somebody to speak in a church who looks
more like Jesus than any picture of
seasons you've ever seen in your entire
lives
[Applause]
that's true nobody thought well at least
they'll remember what race I am Jesus
Lord Jesus he went up there a Middle
Eastern man he came down looking like
the base plan from an indie rock group
in the early noughties
poor Jesus from the King of Kings to a
king of Liang what I like her to be
doing comedy in America I'm also really
here as a diplomatic envoy on behalf of
the British population and I would like
to say on behalf of my nation to the
people of America thank you so much for
electing Donald Trump president I
understand is being received with some
tension in the room genuinely thank you
so much for the Bob our heart for real
acting Donald Trump when you elected
Donald Trump you showed a commitment to
the special relationship you've stood by
our side and not abandoned us when we
needed you the most because it was
brexit then Trump so you saw us commit
geopolitical suicide and instead of
reacting as you should have done which
is to go there but for the grace of God
go we lesson learned you reacted like
this not on your own
[Applause]
now the two of us just got off the edge
of the cliff like Thelma Louise at the
end of the film don't get me wrong I'm
glad it was brexit first then Trump it's
like the office we came up with the idea
the basic premise can we pump in more
money in some high-profile celebrities
because for a hot minute we were the
super dis country in the world then you
elected your 45th president both in
terms of chronology and quality we got
beat by a creditable silver medal
position everybody's very angry in this
country's very angry in my country and
you know there's people who you should
be legitimately angry at like people
should be angry with men let's face it
lads we've had a couple of million years
particularly toxic last year are going
to run to hijacked a truck and he drove
it into a crowd of people and he kill
intended them an engine 50 more and when
the police investigated they found out
that his last Facebook post that day
said that he was leaving to start an
insole revolution now men who existed
are pockets of the Internet and they're
very angry and they're very angry
because they say they are involuntarily
celibate that's what in sells me
involuntarily set in fall into
involuntary involuntarily basically me
between the years 1985 in 2006 I know
that there are some people here going
hold on were you a 21 year old virgin
and to those people let me just say this
shut up shut up it's hard for some boys
also it happened in February and I'm an
August birthday so shut up
so I don't have time for your maths
right listen we are involuntarily
celibate that happens to all of us but
what do we do when that happens we don't
kill people that's weird as we do we
handle our business we go to our rooms
and we masturbate to self-penned Buffy
the Vampire Slayer fan fictions
young cool hipster audience you have no
idea I came of age in the era of dial-up
internet you either way it's 45 minutes
for a JPEG to load or you improvise you
have no idea what it's like now you can
stream HD porn videos on your phone
while you're taking a dump like you all
back in my day we stopped to sit there
waiting for the image so like this to
sustain an erection for weeks was a
weird place asking if you're writing a
letter that's the best now here's the
thing when this in self stuff happened I
thought well people they'll be really
angry about this and Wheatley people
weren't the New York Times published an
article suggesting we have a
redistribution of sex meanwhile in the
UK a magazine published an article
suggesting the government provide free
sex robots to insert right now nice
that's quite frustrating because okay I
am a nice guy no
[Laughter]
listen I am a nice guy but even I have
my limits
okay look at Mike okay I'm just gonna
stay right every time there is a
terrorist attack of any description
I always think two things the first
thing I'm fine with the second thing I'm
embarrassed by by I want to tell you
about in the interest of building
empathy the first thing I think whatever
there's been a terrorist attack is I
hope everyone is okay fine the second
thing I think whatever there's been a
terrorist attack people
no one cares all I'm saying is there's a
cultural imbalance and I'm just trying
to redress it that's all I'm saying I
just think there's a double standard one
way I don't have a problem with white
white Oh have you know that some of my
best stand-up comedy do does have a
point
yeah he does have a point I liked his
his point view I don't know like I like
the way he tailored his sec cuz he was
you know kind of talking to us kind of
making jokes you know but like yeah
really actually kind of getting real so
it's funny the biggest takeaway about
this I was weirdly not really the Trump
stuff you know oh yeah like what
territory are we walking into people
like Stephen Colbert and Seth Meyers and
Trevor Noah
everydays all about Trump right so I was
like okay we're gonna get a giant trunk
attached from Trump dump stand oh yeah
it's like five straight minutes Trump
but I
his opening bid I could relate to the
most about Jesus Christ being blonde
hair blue eyes yeah we grew up in
Catholic school we went to church every
Sunday I've seen Jesus of Nazareth a
bunch of times so white Christ all the
time why'd you save me why Jesus ever
being in science class teachers named
mr. white and Lanigan Lanigan Lanigan
like actually you know science says that
Jesus was probably not religious science
is just history
Jesus Jesus would take a cross section
of the map for who those people are
generally inhabit that area find a white
guy with blond hair and blue eyes but
weird about them it's still ingrained in
my brain though even though I logically
know that when I think of like if
someone says imagine an image of Jesus I
immediately think of blond hair blue
eyed rice right oh yeah I think of the
stereotypical drawing on the wall of
every like church rectory of like Jesus
and sheep hey it's not about what he
looked like it's about what he stood for
and we should probably really
course-correct and make sure everyone
knows that he wasn't a boy don't worry
eventually we're going to get a reboot
Jesus movie where it's like gritty and
realistic be great yeah it's about
Passion of the Christ passionate Mel's
back have you ever seen that movie no I
remember now differently when it came
out you look the most like Jesus I know
I know
arguably I do you just have longer hair
but Jesus had curly they said his hair
was most likely curly yeah see well we
should make a movie where we're both
Jesus we you're like this idea of insel
revolution that's my first time hearing
about this oh wow that well cannot go
over my head what they're talking about
a bunch of angry guys who can't Jack you
late or who at least don't have access
to sex taking it out on the world are
zest yep oh and I believe they have been
slighted and are owed something and they
want to take it out on anyone in
everyone
and there's sex work it's a terrible
crime terrible crime he committed this
is sad terrible crime yeah if they
actually develop like robots just I've
heard they've done already
oh no there's already enough data to
prove how pornography in general just
you gotta realize like porn has been
around for a very long time right cave
painting but internet porn changed every
end just not talking about this is just
you know automatically you miss my
people are talking about let's see what
happens he's making fun of like the days
one of the first internet pornography
but now an internet porn with the rapid
succession that you get the VR porn well
just even before VR just to how
fast-paced everything is how you get
this instant access and how and there's
everything under the Sun like anything
you can imagine and then wanting more
extremity and more extremity it's
effective development of a lot of kids
already it's actually made it even
harder it's made it more challenging
more difficult for people to even get
laid because they've they resort to
pornography but weirdly if you learn to
abstain a little bit when there are
people who obviously watch porn migaila
there are some people depending on your
you know emotional psychological
development where this has become a
crutch where you might where you're less
likely to even go out and seek it
physically you'll be more okay with not
actually getting the real thing then it
creates loneliness lack of intimacy
there's a whole bunch of stuff right so
if they create these work I feel like
you're taking advantage of so much was
the time and a place for certain things
but I can't I think oh just like
anything it will get abused I just think
that it's idiotic to propose robots when
I'm just like if you legitimized sex
work and then made it so that culture
wasn't so hot cold about the entire idea
then you could have a simple system
where someone who doesn't I mean it
doesn't help for your high school age
people who feel this way but anybody
else is over 18 would then be able to
transactionally go out and have an
experience with somebody and think of
how many less angry vengeful people you
could have and and like if you don't
have it be a robot you have to be an
actual human person not to be like cap
in prostitution because there are a lot
of ways that can go wrong but like if
you legitimize that you could solve this
problem John in a whole new way wait
John sex work is totally legal as long
as there's a camera let's do it
prostitution it's not prostitution you
paid her to have sex no I paid her to
have sex and we're filming it so
technically it's not prostitution it's a
porno oh well as long as you're filming
and selling it it's legal remember kids
she's not a [ __ ] if she's an actress if
you only have screens and you only have
porn there's a whole different way your
mind's engaging with that and that
totally changes if you rely on it a ton
your interaction with the world so if
you had legal prostitution that wouldn't
be the same issue and then there's a lot
of porn stars who are not even really
making money now so they resort to
prostitution I mean you get from this
video guys you can actually get a porn
star that's right but I mean I just
heard their situation is a good one and
not a shady bad one it's all kind of
shady there are lots of ways to
prostitute please me white guys feel
like we've had a chicken in like terror
well yeah I mean now it's lately it's
been becoming especially with what
happened in Texas recently that was an
act of racism yet though if someone is
of color always though it's the it's
that races act whereas if a white guy
does it it's an act of racism from a
particular white guy or a group of wipey
yeah I don't like it's like a Muslim
dude it's like I'm not some [ __ ]
hater that's you know it's it's like a
weird yeah we're slowly learning how to
don't like the other group and then when
it's someone of color they really seem
to capitalize that it's on someone of
code yeah it's a weird it's a weird time
to watch all the rudders shift I'm sure
because it's like I do feel like we are
shining more lights on when white people
are the terrorists to to show that it's
not just a racial thing necessarily or
it's not something ingrained in one race
we are far from being in a place where
everybody sees the full picture and is
willing to kind of
heads together I heard a report recently
that Donald Trump has told over 12,000
lies since this time of being president
false claims and a lot of lines I never
thought about putting him out of here -
you need lies I think you tell a couple
and then you wait to get scolded and
then when nobody scolds you you just see
how far you can take it and then when
you realize that there's no one above
you yeah you just kind of keep taking it
well guys I don't know who you're voting
for Bernie Sanders has my vote this year
I'm putting that out for something wrong
publicly Trump reelecting that guy 22 I
wasn't convinced last time now I'm on
board soon for more tears wash that coal
off reinvigorate America universal
healthcare is my primary draw I'm a
little bit of an idealist who identify
as progressive so any major countries
have universal health care we can work
towards getting there I feel like if we
can just give them for even if it's just
for years he's in office with Sanders
and he can get to at least getting us on
the right path to universal health care
that would be bomb diggity man too many
people are rejected at emergency rooms
to me people die going to emergency
rooms too many people don't go because
they can't afford things and then have
worse things happen people can't get the
treatment they need
there's a lot of depth and a lot of
death especially when you meet people
who are from Canada and you hear about
their home country what they got going
on here like reports it's one thing they
hear people talk about it then when you
talk face-to-face with someone who's
visiting from a country that has
universal health care you're like wow we
don't have anything for that that is
nuts it does seem like a fundamental
human right that's my little stance
well JN thanks for requesting this my
dude you know one vote for Jane for
president I would - he has a lot of
thoughts yeah he'd be like the way
Howard Trump spouts off a lot he'd do
that but in like a a more progressive
manner
Shambala he likes like I don't know what
he's talking about but it sounds
positive yeah his honesty record would
be off the chain of problem is the ideas
would be hard to decipher I think it
would bring the country together that
way because we don't be focused in on
what he has to say
what is it me I know it's been a little
rough lately with everything you've got
going on keep taking care of yourself
dude and keep opening up and keep
feeling what you got to feel and and
times of grief it's really just a
challenge and then the growth that you
get to on the way to acceptance tell you
is a beautiful thing you'll come out of
stronger man in the end all right guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell and we'll
catch you guys soon